[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Jade warshaw
joined by George camel author of
Breaking Free from broke it's good to be
with you today George it's been a while
Jade it's going to be fun we're taking
your calls give us a call the number is
88255 225 and we are here to give you
the hookup we'll chop it up with you
let's go straight to the phone lines
where we've got Terell in Berkeley
California what's going on Terell hey
how you doing doing good did I get your
name right yes Terrell is the name let's
go how can we help um I'm just calling
for a little bit of advice on buying a
car um right now I'm uh been saving some
money to buy a car and um I just want
want to make the best decision of either
buying a used car or one that is uh
pre-owned and um I'm actually in the
motion of trying to own a house and I've
been buying used cars for approximately
a couple of years now to save money and
so I won't have a big overhead on cars
or paying a car note so I just trying to
see exactly what's the right decision to
make so you've been you've been in the
process you've been you've currently
bought used cars have you been
purchasing them in cash
yes cash good that's very very good so
are you
considering it sounds like you're
considering two things either continuing
to do that or possibly buying a brand
new car or taking on a car on taking on
a car
note yes yes so what's driving you to
upgrading car no pun
intended um actually my car just broke
down after four years and I'm just uh
tired of the fact of uh you know having
to spend money on mechanical issues with
buying a used car and I just want to buy
something that's uh more prolonged uh
buying a vehicle that I know that I can
trust for a couple of years so that I
don't have to worry about any car issues
yeah in the past how much have you spent
on a used vehicle like what's your
vehicle worth now or when you bought it
U my vehicle that I uh bought was
$2,200 and it lasted me four years after
just a couple of mechanical uh problem
that's some pretty good listen that's
not bad at all um how much money do you
have right now in cash um in cash um
actually I saved up around 80,000
wow yes credit score no no debt always
uh I always watch you guys show about
learning not to uh get in debt I have no
debt at all what do you earn a year I I
earn approximately uh this year I made
94,000 that's doing what what's your
job um I actually do sewer maintenance
okay listen Terrell I'm proud of you
you've been buying cash cars you've been
staying out of debt you managed to save
$80,000 here's the thing when we tell
people to buy cars in cash it is a way
of life right you you draw that Line in
the Sand you're you say I'm not
borrowing money anymore however the idea
of driving a hoopie for life is not
really it is it George like we want you
to slowly but surely upgrade your car
with cash I don't want you driving a
$2,200 car when you're making $94,000 a
year and you have no debt like it's time
to move and on up all right time up that
doesn't mean go to the nearest
dealership and find the shiniest newest
car on the lot that's right so what
what's your net worth right now um my
net worth in all in all total um I will
say that it's around the 880,000 Mark or
plus okay I'd rather just focus on that
as the scoreboard instead of your credit
score cuz you're about to I'm sure you
said you had a great credit score right
yes and you know what the dealer ERS
ship the salesperson is like I'm about
to get Terrell with this car payment
can't wait I'm going to tell him how
great of a job he did with his debt
management score so I'm going to ignore
the credit score and we're going to look
at your income and also tell you that
the time to buy a new car brand new is
when you're a net worth
millionaire exactly cuz you buy a
$40,000 car bro that's half of your net
worth right now like that hurts my brain
so there's a time and for approximately
uh excuse me I've seen a car
approximately for about 15,000 and I was
going to put half of the payment down
and try to slowly uh either make
payments on you have
$15,000 you have $115,000 cash money
that you can go into that dealership you
can buy 15 or $20,000 car walk out Own
It Free and Clear and not owe anybody
anything because here's I don't think
you realize how well you're set up
Terrell um George just outlined it
you're in a situation that you don't
need anything from anybody and credit
scores are for people who think they
need something from somebody like credit
cards are designed for people who think
I can't do this myself I've got to
borrow the money you've already
completely just bashed through that like
you cut out the middle man you already
cut that out exactly and so at this
point the only thing that you have to do
is continue to live the life you're
living and when you start thinking about
the the time to buy real estate start
putting aside the same money the same
way you started saving that 80,000 is
the same thing you're going to do when
it's time to buy a house and that's
really Terell you've you've already
knocked out one of the two kingpins of
the no credit Lifestyle the car cuz some
so many people think you can't buy a car
in cash and continue to buy cars in cash
you've already crushed that like you got
it and the next thing is the house and
so for you that's after you get through
this car thing the house is your next
big goal and you'll save that down
payment and you'll be able to buy that
with a zero credit score as well so in
your situation it's better to have a
zero credit score no credit score right
which means you're not messing around
around with debt at all than to try to
play this game and maybe if I take out a
little bit on my car and pay that for a
while or maybe if I pick up this little
credit card here it's a game that you
have already decided I'm not playing
like you've already changed the game in
your life so don't go back and try to
play a loser game because you're already
a
winner fair enough okay yes that's fair
enough what kind of car are you looking
at um I was looking at a Honda Court yes
okay this guy like low maintenance Honda
Accord or toota Camry listen come on
with come on with the Camry there we go
these are these are the reliable cars
we're talking about that thing will
outlive me and so I'm going to go with
one of those you can find them for 15 or
20 grand you're going to walk in there
you don't have to walk in with a
briefcase of cash M you just say hey I'm
looking for the out the door price
that's what you ask for and then you're
going to get a pre- purchase inspection
to make sure there's no mechanical
issues and what happened right there is
someone else paid the depreciation on
that vehicle for you when you buy a used
car someone else took the hit cuz they
paid $388,000 MSRP and Terrell got it
for 15,000 that's a deal cuz new cars
depreciate much faster than used cars
they go down in value Trail get this 60%
in the first five
years okay and so by buying used you're
being a really smart consumer and one
day you'll be driving a brand new car
when you got a million dollar net worth
and if you want an accord you just walk
on the lot and you choose that Accord if
you want something fancier you've earned
the right to do it and so this is going
to help you build wealth by making these
decisions now Terrell how old are you
yes sir yeah um I'm 33 come on 33 years
old killing it killing it proud of very
very good and it's so it's so hard
living in the Bay Area due to the fact
that you know the cost of living is so
high we have a lot of high interest
rates of buying vehicles and buying
homes so that's why I just been really
just trying to save as much money as
possible because my first goal was to
buy a home yeah and you know that's why
I've been buying used vehicles to try to
keep saving up buy home you're doing
everything right you're doing everything
right keep doing that stay out of debt
practice the life staying out of debt
you know this you're doing the right
thing you've you've saved up the money
to buy a much nicer car in cash and
that's what ultimately we want for you
you're not driving a hoopie for life
you're upgrading and with your income
you can definitely easily afford to pay
$5 $20,000 for a used car and he's not
trying to impress anyone he's imp
impressing future Terrell I like that
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health Health expenses
but we have found a solution that works
for us in an incredible way she loves
that with chm she can help other
families who need it and receive help
back when her own family has an eligible
medical event chm has been a godsend for
Jenna that's her chm story and it could
be yours learn more and join at
chministries.org
budget
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
your host Jade warshot next to me is
George camel host of the YouTube show
the George Campbell show also author of
the book Break Free Breaking Free from
broke which is out now in the wild
Georgia so fun to see it arrive at
people's homes and the reviews have been
just wonderful people are changing their
lives Jade 17 to 51 cutting up credit
cards stitching the credit score very
encouraging you love to see it love it
so if you haven't gotten a copy be sure
to get your copy I've got mine uh let's
take a call let's go to Molly who's in
Boston Massachusetts what's going on
Molly hi thanks for having me um so my
husband pass pass away four years ago
sorry about that and thank you um so I
have benefits um from his death um so I
live very comfortably on the income that
I have um however I'm getting um a
couple onetime payments okay
um that I don't quite know what to do
with it's a sub substantial amount of
money and I don't know like I lost a lot
of money in the crash in 2008 uhhuh um
through my 401k and stuff so I'm a
little Leary to do that well you only
lost it if you pulled it out did you
pull it out I did okay okay we'll
consider that as we move forward but
keep talking okay okay so um like I said
I live comfortably on what I have um
when I take vacations I prepay my credit
card um with my guesstimated you know
what it's going to cost okay um so that
I don't actually incur debt but I feel
it's safer than using my debit card and
you can't run a car with you know a
debit card so okay we'll talk about that
too okay okay um so I have these two
lump thums coming in and I don't really
know what to do with them and um my bank
offers a 5.5 um% interest on
CDs so I've considered like every two
weeks putting in a substantial amount of
money um so that how much I need it how
much are these single payments going to
be and how many of them do you think
you'll
get um the total for the two are 555,000
okay 555,000 wow for two and you're
getting it two times okay um no it's a
total one that'll be one time that's the
total of the two okay oh got it okay so
they're they'll give you 225 for one and
225 for the other or whatever or
whatever it is 275 okay so let me ask
you a few questions now just to put it
all together so do you have any other
debt like do you have any debt on the
books do you have a mortgage can you
tell me a little bit more about your
financial situation as far as income and
debt okay so I I did purchase a house um
last
May and I purchased it for $429 I put
115,000 down on it okay so my mortgage
payment now is um 2500 a month
okay no other debt no other debt uh cars
paid
for I'm driving a 16-year-old truck okay
now other than this other than this 555
that's coming um do you have any other
money
saved um I do not um just because I just
bought the house and had to furnish it
and everything um but my monthly
income
is
um
7200 okay so you bring about 70 7200
home every month and what about
children um out of the house okay okay
so George jump in at any time so I'm
looking at this situation and I'm
filtering it through our teaching here
at Ramy I don't know how um familiar you
are with it but we we view everything
through seven baby steps and these baby
steps are what we feel are the fastest
path to wealth with the most amount of
Peace least amount of stress all right
so that's everything I'm talking to you
is going to be through that so with you
it's great because I just recalculated
because I I actually bring in 7400 a
month oh excellent love it love the
increase okay so with you because you
don't have any debt that's excellent
It's kind of jumping us to the third
baby step which is making sure you have
3 to six months saved so if it were me
and I woke up in your shoes that would
be my first thing that I'm going to gun
for I'd think okay what do I need what
are what would constitute 6 months of
expenses for for me and I would work at
getting those saved when are you getting
that first
payment um within a couple months okay
so between now and then I'm going to use
my income and I'm going to start to
build up that that 3 to six months of
savings so that's thing one that I'm
focused on is how can I get six months
of savings thing number two that I'm
going to focus on in your case just
because I think everybody needs a budget
is I'm going to start a budget the
budget we recommend here is every dollar
and you're going to want that going
forward now that you've got this house
you've just got this new life in front
of you with new expenses and new money
and a new relational situation it's just
a whole new life for you and having a
budget is going to give you a lot of
Peace month to month of how you're
spending your money okay so that's Thing
One and Thing Two now I'm looking at
this money and George is going to talk
to you more about the investing side of
things because I think that's worth
noting but right as we've talked about
saving and budgeting I want to go back
to what you said earlier about your
credit card and it being safe versus a
debit card if I were you I would think
really um seriously um about cutting up
my credit cards and deciding that I'm
going to live a debt-free lifestyle cuz
for you it's easier than ever and you
don't need the credit card you don't
need it you got money in the bank and so
as far you're worried more about safety
it sounds
like yeah I've had my um debit card um
compromised several times and I found
that it's easier um if that happens when
you're traveling um to have your credit
card because it's not your real money
it's their money and I found that it
gets resolved a lot quicker and you know
so that just makes me nervous because if
I'm unless I'm traveling and I'm using
my debit card and it get gets
compromised then I'm stuck I've never I
can vouch for this I've visited I've
traveled to over 92 countries I've never
had a problem with them restoring the
money to a debit card account George you
just talked about this the protections
are exactly the same as as long as you
call and say if your if your debit card
has a Visa or MasterCard logo you're
covered under their zero liability
policy and there's even a federal law
the electronic fund transfer act
protects debit cards in cases of fraud
as long as you report it within 60 days
and so on top of that renting a car
every single major rental car company
has their own debit card policy and so
there may be a slightly bigger hold on
your checking account which you have the
buffer for but you'll have no problem
doing that yeah those compan definitely
make it a little hard harder but you can
still do it I it will reduce reduce your
risk um as well as give you more peace
when you just use your own money now and
I talk about this in my new book Molly
so I'm going to send you a copy because
I cover how to rent a car without a
credit score why you should ditch the
credit card and even the CDs and why I'm
not a big fan of the certificates of
deposit you mentioned what's going to
happen there is it's going to lock that
money up and if you withdraw it before
it matures the maturity date you're
going to have to pay a penalty of losing
some of the interest and so you can
actually that me that rate you mentioned
is what I'm getting right now in my high
yield savings account which is
completely liquid there's no penalties
if I take the money out so I would
encourage you just as you pause and
decide what's next to put the money in a
high yield savings account that's what I
would do and that's what I do as well so
I think that that kind of gives you some
just lifestyle changes to consider
cutting up the credit cards living a
cash lifestyle um that's good to
consider and then finally if I'm you um
as this money is rolling in the the way
we teach the baby steps let me just roll
through them real quick so you get the
context number one is for people who are
first starting out they just get $1,000
saved number two is for people who have
Consumer Debt they pay off all of their
debt except the house number three is
where you're technically at which is
saving 3 to six months of expenses then
from there on people do four five and
six simultaneously so because I know
you're going to have six months saved up
quickly let's talk about those real
quick baby step four is you're investing
15% of your income every single month so
I want to make sure that we start that
habit for you and then if you have kids
that are going to college baby step five
you can do this at the same time you can
start setting some money aside for
college if it makes sense and then
finally baby step six you can start
putting extra money towards your house
so putting that in context for you if
I'm you I'm going to start putting that
15% aside like on autopay coming out of
my check every month and I'm going to
start looking at when this
$555,000 comes how I can start paying my
home off woo emotional decision but it
is a wonderful one to make and you'll
still have over 200 grand left over to
max out retirement to give more to enjoy
life and spend more and to upgrade that
16-year-old truck Molly it's time it is
time so hang on the line we're going to
send you a copy of Breaking Free from
broke it'll walk you through all of the
stuff we talked about and hopefully help
you have a new paradigm around it man
what a blessing to have life insurance
not fun but man it changes things
absolutely this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
the home buyer Edge from Churchill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
you are listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw joined by George camel and
I just want to thank you guys so much
for tuning into the show week after week
thank you for hanging out with us on
YouTube or whatever podcast service you
use thank you for sharing the show with
the folks around you and we want you to
continue doing that wherever you consume
the show we would love if you took a
moment to like the show or subscribe to
the show it means a lot to us when you
do that even when you just send a link
through a text to a friend friend of one
of your favorite episodes that means a
lot not only for us but also to the
person that you're sharing it with
there's so much great information on
this show so when you share it it not
only helps that person but it helps us
more and more people see the show and
the algorithm and it is just a wonderful
chain of events that takes place so if
you've been doing it keep doing it if
you've never done it before just take a
second it's free it takes two seconds of
your time and the result of it is
massive it's a great return on
investment George as the the financial
would say that's right uh so thank you
so much for doing that it means a lot to
us and let's head over to the phone
lines where we got molly in New Orleans
Louisiana what's going on
Molly hi everyone how are y'all we're
doing good how are you I've been better
we're in a bit of a sticky situation and
I'm calling to kind of get y'all's
advice on how we should address uh a
pretty big financial situation our
dishwasher busted flooded our
and we are down to slab the slab and the
stud basically yikes and yeah it's not
ideal I'm six months pregnant and I have
two small children oh no oh
no not exactly a convenient time right
um big problem we've run into is
insurance is denying our claim so it's
looking like we're goingon to have to
pay for this entire renovation out of
pocket oh so this isn't just a
dishwasher you have to replace flooring
oh yeah I mean I it floors it ruin
cabinet um a little bit yeah we're gonna
have to replace some drywall some
insulation what's the price
tag so I'm waiting for my full estimate
because I went and I picked um like
materials today to go pick out fling and
things like that um but on cabinets and
then the demolition alone is 177,000 and
that's not having you know
that's not anything to do with floors my
countertops
Etc um where we are fortunate is that um
we do have money saved from uh saved and
invested that my husband inherited after
his mother had passed away um but we're
looking I guess for the best way to use
that money in order to pay for it
because we really don't want to have to
take out a personal loan or go into any
sort of debt to find well that's off the
table so let's
let's let's look at this as though debt
is doesn't even exist in in the world
and I like to look at situations that
way because it it it then takes it off
the table and it frees my mind to be
very creative in my Approach so from
this moment on there's no such thing as
debt we don't even it doesn't even exist
in the world so let's talk about it like
that um you mentioned that there's some
money that you have but you also
mentioned that it was invested can you
tell me more about
that I can tell you I guess generally my
husband tends to be the one to run the
investment side of things um but from
him we do have um he said there's 59,000
in a high yield savings account good
it's 53,000 invested in stocks and bonds
to specific ones I can't speak to
personally at this time I I just don't
look look the
59,000 is where I'm at right now um that
high yield savings account just covered
this renovation didn't it listen I know
it did
there's another 11,000 he said in a uh
he said it's called a money market
account it's like a cash yeah okay so
listen the good news is you guys have
the cash to cash flow this and that's
really comforting and good good for you
guys for making sure that that safety
net is in place do you I'm just curious
do you have any other debt that we
should know about that plays a role in
this um not really I mean we have um a
mortgage um fine and then we only have
we were completely debt free until about
the last year we have about 5,000 in
credit cards and that was three out of
four family members wound up in the
hospital at some point so very sudden
random unforeseen circumstances that
happened aside from that both cars are
paid off good okay no other Deb so so
5,000 clears all of your Consumer
Debt yes let's
to love it we're clearing that debt out
today I love that you still have extra
money left to get this kitchen fixed and
to repair these damages I don't think
you're going off the wall I don't know
that you have to spend you know every
dime that you have but what I do want
you to get from this um and what I'm my
takea away from this situation Molly is
um you guys have done a good job you've
kind of played patty cake with your
finances in a way that it's like oh we
can take out some debt for this maybe we
can consider it for for this because I
have a feeling that if you hadn't called
in you guys might have taken out a
personal loan to cover something that
you can pay cash for and cash flow
throughout your life and your situation
and so my takea away from this would be
coming off of this call I would have you
and your husband really get on a good
budget because that's what's going to
inform your lifestyle from here on out
and I think when you have a good budget
it's tell it's giving you like this
snapshot of what your entire financial
situation looks like so when something
comes up like family members getting ill
you're not going oh I'm not sure if we
have the money for it so let's just use
the credit card or if something you know
like a catastrophy pops up like with
this dishwasher you're not thinking oh
our only option might be to get out a
personal loan you've got all your
finances in one place and of course the
budget we recommend is every dollar
because you can see everything about
your finances and that one app and it
just kind of gives you that peace of
mind to go in your case you would look
at that and go oh my gosh we're doing
far better than what I realized and we
can pay cash we don't have to go into
debt or stress or or monthly payments in
order to deal with something honestly as
big as a dishwasher flood in the house I
love that you guys have $59,000 really
uh $62,000 saved it's amazing that's
save the bacon today and Molly a few
things to consider number one you may
want to consider appealing the claim
denial with insurance if you feel like
you have good reason to believe it
should be covered is that the case and
that's that's been battle the last two
weeks I think the next step is seeking
out some legal advice um which is you
know an Avenue that we're willing to
explore it's um I feel it was definitely
a premature denial of our claim um and
then I fought back and fought back and
fought back they kind of uh sent someone
out I think to appease me maybe you know
let someone come take a look so I had
someone in my house but then you know
they're still maintaining a denial which
maybe I'm in denial maybe I just not
willing to accept that well if if the
appliance was old it wasn't maintained
properly there was negligence you know
there's a lot of things that would cause
the denial but I'm just I if it takes a
month of fighting to make that 25 Grand
needed for renovations I'm fighting it
so that's one angle the second is to
make sure you get multiple bids on this
don't just take the first bid from the
first guy who says they can fix it so
I'd get m multiple bids I would try to
negotiate and say hey we can pay upfront
with cash if you're able to give us a
discount and see what they
say yeah and a lot of times you'll get
4% off which adds up when it's $225,000
of work listen wait I might I might go
against that George what's that with
cash you talking about with the
contractors well with the whatever the
bid is that's true but I would never pay
contractor up front well when the work
is done but I'm saying like some people
will go on payments or something like
that you oh saying no no payment plan I
got you I got you hey we'll write you a
check when this is done okay yeah cuz I
was about to say when the guy comes in
when they swipe a card there's fees
involved that they have to pay and so if
that's a 3% fee and you say hey can I
get a 3% discount if I just write you a
check just simple things like that can
save you money so I'd get multiple bids
and do your best to just lower this cost
because I know it's a stressful time
you're 6 months pregnant you got two
kids running around like crazy and I'd
also get more details on this inves side
what your husband's doing you should
have some clarity and understanding of
everything going on with your financial
picture but I definitely agree with that
listen not fun that water is one of the
most
Insidious things that can happen in your
home it is just the worst especially in
her situation 6 months pregnant two kids
on the way oh I felt her pain I just
want to say not today sat not today I
know that's right George oh but
thankfully they had the safety net of
emergency fund a fully fully fully
funded emergency fund that's what you
need uh when life storms hit this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys ramsy solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switch to net Suite it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll Company
netw Suite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation
more than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netsuite today and find out
how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
Net's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsy show I am Jade warshaw
your host joined by George camel your
other host George wrote the book
Breaking Free from broke I wrote the
book money is not a math problem and so
listen just two authors sitting in
chairs talking about things just doing
the dang thing George that's what I'm
talking about so how has it been tell me
a little bit about the journey here of
this this book here well writing a book
is one of the hardest things I think
I've ever had to do especially when it
lives in the world of Total Money
Makeover and what's been really
encouraging though is people going like
this is Dave Ramsey said this is
financial piece for the Next Generation
reviews are saying this is like total
money over ber written for
2024 with me in mind all of the
objections all of the struggles I've
been dealing with the last few years
with inflation and the housing market
and what do we do now and credit scores
and credit cards there's so many more
traps than there was even 10 years ago
and so I covered all in this book to
help you have this paradigm shift and go
I don't need to play this game Building
Wealth and living a life I want to live
is so much simpler than I thought I just
got to ditch this money Matrix that's
been created for me so money matx the
reviews have been aome awesome and I
love your book hit the best seller list
Jade congratulations I did not even know
that that was possible George because
you love will find a way you have a what
I'm going to call full-sized book and I
have the miniature version which is a
quick read and uh I I didn't know it was
possible but here we stand in the
National bestseller cat yes cool that
means people are getting helped that's
right and that's what we're here to do
help you guys help you with your money
situations your relationship situations
mental health situations career
situations all of that is directly
connected in your life so that's what we
talk about on the show your life and
your money so you can give us a call the
number is 8825 5225 and we will do
exactly that and let's do it now going
to Taylor in Washington DC what's going
on Taylor yes well first congratulations
to you both on your uh new book releases
gracias and claps to that um I am
calling because I not I'm I'm in a
little bit of a situation to where um
currently I own my home um I also have
an investment property okay the
investment property is doing well in
terms of um just the equity aspect so at
the moment it has about
$150,000 worth of equity that's in it
however I'm really not making anything
off of it too much I find that I'm
actually giving putting out money so
like for example 2023 I probably spent
$2,000 2500 something like that just
kind of doing repairs that maybe the
rent wasn't able to cover um and so I'm
in this little mix of um you know
understanding that real estate is the
best part to wealth I have a home um
with my with my husband that we um that
we own still have a mortgage on of
course how much um and so the idea was
to acquire more properties in a sense um
but now I'm starting to have this idea
of do I offload the property at 140
15,000 uh where I will be able to get
that equity and possibly just pay off my
student loan where I currently have
about 880,000 uh because I ended up
getting my MBA and obviously as a result
um you know like a lot of other people
racked up a lot of debt with that what
otherb you have my revolving debt I only
have about 15 thou say only but I have
about $15,000 in revolving debt which
includes my car note uh credit cards uh
things like that so H not sure of which
way to go what about your husband what
debt does he
have uh my husband probably has about
10,000 worth of debt and that also
includes uh vehicles and credit cards
okay so he has 10,000 cars and credit
cards he doesn't have student loan debt
uh he does I'm sorry yes he does he's
he's less than mine so I think he's 40
he's about 40,000 now okay so 40K in
student loan from him okay so there's a
lot here Taylor I'm not going to lie to
you this is
A50 Grand in just Consumer Debt yeah mhm
so what is what's the investment
property
worth uh right now it is worth I could
probably get like 360 at the minimum the
high would be 380 and I owe
199,000 okay and you're thinking after
fees you'd walk away with about
130 yes yeah yeah take about yeah after
after all of the the credits and things
like that at least you guys have any
money in the bank right now in savings
yes we do we have um we have about four
months worth of our living expenses how
much is that
um we
are it's about
40,000 in our yeah do you guys have
stocks like single stocks or single
single Investments I do but it's not
much in there I only have about $6,000
in my single stock and obviously not not
including uh 401ks or anything like that
and do you have a brokerage or anything
else that we should know about uh no
that's probably it for the most part and
what's the household
income uh combined we are about
240 woo good job okay good and uh okay
so I know George I'm looking at these
numbers and I'm just seeing a situation
that's so complex that doesn't have to
be complex it looks like when you just
said all of that it was just even a lot
to say like to list all that out was a
lot to say we had to take a deep breath
at the end we had to like wipe the sweat
off of our brow um I think that there's
a way to really simplify this and in my
mind it does start with selling that
rental because it's going to give you
the cash you need to get a hold of your
life and to simplify your life and then
and only then you'll be able to do the
thing that you want to do which is
purchase real estate and you'll be able
to do it the right way so I kind of feel
like have you ever seen um on the movies
where the guy like clears the table off
and he like just uses his hands to like
knock everything off like I did with the
microphone and and then you got like the
clear slate I feel like that's what we
have to do with this is just knock
everything off the table and start over
and I think that selling this real
estate is the way to do that you're
going to clear like you said about 130
and then we've also got 40,000 saved on
our debt and I think or saved in saved
in savings account if you take that
money you can be debt free immediately
with most of your emergency fund on top
of that cuz you're going to have like
176 if you include the stocks if you
sell those to that 176 is going to clear
your debt and leave with a fully funded
emergency fund how good would that feel
it would feel great now it's a little
intimidating so we are in our early 40s
so it's like it also is like feeling
like starting over with
rebuilding what you what are you
rebuilding you're clearing the deck here
in the best way possible you got no
payments and you make 240 I think you're
going to be okay you you're not
rebuilding right now you're 400 lb mhm
and you're out of shape and what we're
doing right here when you do this you're
going to be 160 and lean like that's
what we're doing for you cuz right now
you're overweight it's stressful it's
heavy it's a lot to carry and by you
doing this it's it's literally getting
you financially fit is what we're doing
and when you're able to be fit then it's
like okay I can move better I can think
clearer and you're going to be able to
do what you want to do ultimately which
it sounds like you guys are interested
in real estate but now you're cleared up
to be able to do it the right way which
is ultimately paying cash for it after
you've paid off your home so there's a
there's a a right there's a right and a
wrong way to do certain things and
there's a better and a best way to do
things and we're trying to tell you the
right better best way to get where you
want to go right right fair enough fair
enough thank you guys I don't think
you're going to regret this decision I
don't think so either but I do think and
it's worth noting while you're on the
line I do think there's a certain
meeting of the minds that you and your
husband are going to have to come to too
and um I do you know when you get off
this call tonight you guys get home and
you're having dinner and you talk about
this what what is that conversation look
like to
you uh we'll probably both be on
different
chapters that's what I thought is he
gonna want to hang on to the de yeah and
and and that's what and that's what made
it hard a little bit to move forward um
with with decision making of trying to
find that alignment um I feel like
slowly we're getting there you know but
it's like each of us presenting our case
in a sense um and so it's like you said
trying to have that meeting of the minds
and find like that Mutual decision well
here's what I would suggest I wouldn't
suggest you going straight away tonight
and be like I was on the radio and these
two Blockheads told me to do D D D D D I
would suggest you taking a moment to get
your head around what we've just said
cuz what we told you a lot and there is
an emotional component to that and there
is an emotional like it's just a lot so
I would recommend you taking a moment to
get your head around it figuring out how
you feel about it that way you're
presenting your case not georgiz case
because if it's not real to you and if
you don't have a a genuine connection to
it it's not going to go over well and um
I think that's important to note George
yeah you guys make
$240,000 there is no reason to play with
debt anymore you're too successful
you're too smart you know too much to
stay broke it's time it's time the time
is now this is the ramsy show
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Jade warshaw
I am joined by George camel today one of
my favorite co-hosts of all time wow of
the book Breaking Free from Brook we're
taking your calls the number is8 825
5225 so give us a call and we would be
happy to help you out with whatever the
concerns you have about your life and
your money but George I have to say I'm
really excited because we have just
recently announced a new event here at
Ramsey Solutions it's a big one brand
new new content new talks Total Money
Makeover
weekend that's it like I was waiting for
like cheers and like and Total Money
Makeover weekend I'm really excited
because it's really Total Money Makeover
is the book that started really all of
this hoopla the baby steps all of that
and so we're creating a live event
weekend around that it's May 10th and
11th and as George said it's all the
personalities like we'll all be there
the goat himself Dave Ramsey will be
there and we're all going to do all new
content on really the same money
Concepts that we've taught for 30 years
around here so if you're you know new to
the ram
way of life this is a great event for
you if you've been hanging out with us
for the last 20 years this is a great
event for pep in your step yeah it's
rally you a reminder of what you're
doing this all for that's right that's
right so uh it's it's here it's here now
early birad tickets start at just $99
but they're for a limited time so make
sure that you get your tickets now you
can do that at ramsy solutions.com
events but I'm looking for it it's going
to be a different format than a lot of
our other events there's Q&A sessions
yeah this is a two-day event Friday and
Saturday we got smart money happy hour
live with Rachel Cruz and I on Friday
night so we and musical experiences so
it's a whole weekend in Nashville make
plans to be here that's right get your
lodging and transportation in the budget
and come hang out with us lodging I like
that lodging Yes again go to ramsy
solutions.com events in order to get
your early bird tickets I'll see you
there all right let's go to Spokane
Washington the city I was born in to
talk to Isaiah what's going on
Isaiah hi how y'all doing doing good
what's going on in
Spokane uh I am here in Spokane training
to be a missionary pilot mechanic um I'm
in my second year okay uh so my question
is is I have some money in a 529 College
plan for my great grandma it's about
31,000 uh I've paid for school the last
two years out of my personal savings and
my wife and I are making enough to where
we could probably pay for school for the
next three years of the program my
question is is should I keep the money
in the 529 or roll it over um into some
other Investments that way it isn't
locked up um and we have access to it to
whether that be reimburse what we spent
on school so far or to just make sure we
have the funds to remain out of debt
moving forward I I would definitely use
the 529 to pay for college because if
you wait and try to use it after the
fact whether you have loans or things
like that there's limits on you using
that money to pay off student Lo or
anything like that so if the money is
earmarked for Education which it is in a
529 I would use that money and then you
use your personal income and cash flow
to do whatever baby step you're on and
if it happens to be investing then you
would use it there does that make sense
yes um so if I've already spent some of
my personal money uh for the 529 plan
can that come back into to reimburse
what I've spent or does it have to be
current and future College expenses what
you spent um let's see you're asking if
you can use the 529 to reimburse what
you've already spent I believe you can
well you'll have to look into it because
they're different by state okay and
George it looks like George might be
looking at that right now yeah I know
you can do that against like if you get
a scholarship you can then take that
withdrawal against the scholarship with
no fees or penalties but as far as just
going hey I paid tuition last year can I
take the money out now I'm not sure
about that based on the plan mhm and I
know that if it was a student loan like
if you're like hey I have a student loan
I think you can only do like 10,000 um
out of a 529 to cover a student loan per
year so there's some stipulations around
that which is another reason why from
here on forward I would just use that
money to pay for Education now you're
and that that just frees up your income
to do life you know do life on a daily
and monthly basis uh with your wife so
you've got 31,000 in the 529 is that
going to cover everything that you
need uh yes I mean for the last two
years it's only been about 5,000 a
semester um which we've covered and
moving forward I've gotten a lot of
really good scholarships and stuff so
even if I were to take it against the
scholarship um I could definitely use
that money I had a this year I had about
18,000 in scholarships I got so um if
what you mentioned you can use a
scholarship to take the money out um in
place of that so yeah we could
definitely use the funds um and then
whatever is left you know if it can roll
over to different family members so if
your uh wife has further education if
you guys end up having children
depending on the state you should be
able to roll it towards different family
members as well and the good news is
over time I believe a 529 by the time
you're in your 60s it becomes just part
of your retirement if I'm not mistaken
but there's some flexibility there the
point is when money is earmarked for a
certain purpose especially when it's
invested money you definitely want to
use it for the purpose that is earmarked
for um cuz it's better off is was there
any other part of that that you had
questions or concerns
about
um no U the only question is is like if
I were to roll it out or take it out for
school um that would free up some of our
savings money absolutely should I just
keep getting just grow the savings or
should we start investing um as a
missionary pilot I'm only going to be
able to fly um for missionary Aviation
till I'm about
63 um in that field because they kind of
cut you off before you get too old um
fly flying isn't the easiest uh so I was
wondering if I should start investing
sooner um knowing that I won't have to
save as much for college because we'll
be using that plan um I yeah that would
be good idea if you got no debt
emergency fund you're able to cash flow
all of your program U 100% then you can
begin investing now but just make sure
do the math on all this and make sure
you're not going to get to year three
and go oh gosh more expensive than we
thought so figure out all of the
expenses needed whether that's housing
and textbooks and who knows what else
are is involved here MH is your wife
working uh yes she works uh full-time as
a nanny so that is one nice um okay and
you don't have any debt nope no debt um
will you be making money while in
school uh I work a little bit my school
is 40 hours a week um and then homework
on top of that so it's not the most
friendly to work as well but I try to
pick up stuff here and there okay that's
the part to think about is you may have
a reduction in income and so I don't
want you guys to you know use up all
that emergency fund because you're in
school yeah and and I'd be I'd be
working now with whatever money you have
left over to build a separate emergency
fund like you've got this 529 money what
other money do you have uh we have uh
about 5 6,000 in savings um and then our
monthly expenses um we don't pay rent or
utilities or cars or phone bills or
anything our parents have have blessed
us with all of that so our monthly
expense is about $1,500 a month so
that's around that four month listen if
I'm you if I'm you I'm going to stock up
that emergency fund in 6 months I'm
going to make sure I'm on an every
dollar budget so I know what the plan is
and I know what we're working towards
and for you it's getting six months
saved and eventually you'll be investing
15% of your income every month into
Investments and re
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything cost too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw this is George Campell host
of the YouTube show the George Campbell
show George how's that show going by the
way it's honestly Bonkers Jade I don't
know you know January is always a big
month for all of our shows but ours in
particular has gone zoom zoom our friend
Dave would say and so right now I don't
know what's going on but we had a really
strong episode with Dave it was
millionaires in cars getting coffee with
Dave and I in a Tesla and we went to his
barn it was there was behind the scenes
he made me a cup of coffee from a fancy
coffee machine and we had a great
conversation was the coffee good though
it was good yeah I got no complaints I
that felt like it wasn't that good
well I don't want to I don't want to dog
Dave you know I got very bougie with my
coffee but it was a great cup so we
enjoy you can go check it out on YouTube
at uh just search George camel with the
K on YouTube and you'll see all stuff to
love it all right let's take your call
by the way you can give us a call the
numers 8825 5225 and we'll answer your
questions so let's go to James and
Cleveland Ohio what's going on
James hey how's it going thanks for
taking my call you're welcome how can we
help so I make um about $80,000 a year I
have about 8 $5,000 in Consumer Debt
spread out between a car payment a
personal loan and some credit cards okay
um can you tell us can you tell us how
it spreads out just so we know yeah so I
have um 40 thou 43,000 on a uh 2021
truck 24,000 on a personal loan and then
the rest is credit card okay thank
you um back in SE
September I started working with this
company um that is you know supposed to
negotiate with these credit card
companies and the personal loan company
to help uh bring the balance down these
debt settlement relief
companies yes yes
exactly and so just recently finding you
guys I'm coming to the horrible
realization that this was a bad idea and
to the point where most of these
accounts are defaulted um or you know
not going to work with meally um so I
don't really know where to go from there
in the baby steps um I have $1,000 fund
saved but as far as like tackling the
debt the truck itself is the only thing
that's active if you will is upside down
p on every month no so we're selling the
truck first off that's what I'm doing
because a guy who's making 880,000
probably shouldn't have a car that's
more than half of his
annual income that's kind of just a rule
of thumb that we go by around here and I
mean yours is just a little above but
considering your debt if I were woke up
in your shoes the first thing I would do
is sell that car and I love you so many
people call in James that are upside
down in their vehicles and it kind of
puts a wrench in the plan I mean they're
still able to do it but because you're
not upside down if you sold that car
today what would you get real close
regardless um but I I my my question
with that would be is I travel for work
and my vehicle is is like my lifeline um
every 6 weeks to 3 months I'm going to a
different part of the country um I build
retail stores for a living um so I mean
having having a vehicle with a warranty
was kind of why I went with a a new
vehicle when I purchased it in the first
place so you're are you you're hauling
things in the truck because of your work
like it's a work
truck yes so you're saying that there's
no way that you could have half the
truck have a $23,000 truck do the same
thing cuz no I guess that's not the case
yeah cuz I'm not listen I'm not telling
you that you have to get a a $2,000
truck I'm just saying I think there's a
significant downgrade that you can do in
the situation and I'm saying that that's
what we're working up to thing one here
is we're paying off your debt that's
what we've got that's that's the house
that's on fire that's what we've got to
be focused on and part of that the
reason that your house is on fire is cuz
you got a $43,000 truck so if we can
knock that down for the time being5 a
month or something if we can knock that
down for the time being to far less
expensive that is going to get you where
you want to go and then the time's going
to come where you can upgrade slowly to
get back to a $40,000
truck sure so would I attack the truck
uh get rid of the truck and then start
working on this Deb that's now going to
collections and stop working with this
stop giving them money so what these
companies do James and now you know this
is they'll intentionally tell you hey
stop paying all payments on this let it
tank and then we'll try to negotiate the
payment to make it lower which in turn
just implodes your financial life and
really doesn't solve the problem and by
the way you could have done that
yourself yeah and so these companies are
borderline scam and I hate them with a
burning passion but yeah we need to get
rid of this truck and downgrade for now
which is going to free up a payment you
said how much is the payment on this
truck um it is 835 Oh Lordy listen James
$835 do you know that's so much money
that is so so much money you're going to
be able to make such great Headway um
before you sell the truck obviously
you're going to need to set aside some
cash that you can get a car in cash and
again remember this is just shortterm
like I understand everything you said
about your your truck being your
livelihood in many ways but this is just
such a short-term sacrif
because with $835 saved up or you know
saved in your budget every month you're
going to be able to pay off $10,000
$111,000 in credit cards licky split
you're going to be able to pay off that
$24,000 loan licky split because I know
that's not the only money that you'll be
able to free up to put towards this
debt yeah sure absolutely and James the
other issue with using this truck for
work a new expensive truck is that you
were destroying the value by taking this
thing on the road like that and so you
need to get out of this thing why you
can and you're not underwater he's lucky
he's not already with the with the miles
you put another 10 20 30 40,000 miles on
this thing and that value is just going
to drop like a rock so that's that's
that's your homework coming out of here
your homework is hey we tell everybody
to get on a budget so make sure you pull
up an every dollar budget that's just
going to help you that's your road map
going forward um and then number two
you're going to start saving up a little
bit of cash so that as soon as possible
you can sell this car and have some cash
to get just an just in the meantime
because once you sell that car it's
going to take you a year to get out of
this debt of or less eight eight I'm
going to say 8 to 12 months to pay this
off if you get after
it fair enough okay and yeah and I'm not
entirely alone here I do have a fiance
and two children at home um I have a
seven-year-old and a one-year-old um so
it makes it a little difficult for my
fiance to um you know help in the income
Endeavor as of now we don't really have
strong support syst system around um but
as well I don't think she should help
you yet because you're not married yet
so until you get married I do even
though you might be living together
financially keep it separate and this is
your debt until you guys do get married
CU her credit card Deb is in total with
that 85,000 okay okay so thank you for
the clarification for right now when do
you guys get married together 12 years
so oh you've been together 12 years but
when do you get
married yeah good question listen James
James you just flipped the entire script
on us right here you done ticked off the
wrong Jade no I'm not mad I'm not mad I
just wish I had this information sooner
listen number one get married and stop
playing if you've been together 12 years
you got two kids together this is the
woman and if it's not real wedding and
it's just not in the in the table fin I
get that but literally just get the
piece of paper because this is for legal
protection for both of you and if you
guys want to do the party later that's
fine but get the piece of paper so that
you can combine your money and it's safe
for both of you like just talk her and
be like listen girl we've been together
all this time come down to the
courthouse with me let's get this paper
signed you don't even have to tell
anyone all right that can be your little
secret until it's this is just to keep
you safe under the law of combining your
things together because if something
happens you want to show that you were
legally married fincial legal
protections with marriage so that's
right so that's you got some work to do
James James thanks for telling us you
just he just entered the fire by telling
us last minute 12
years listen get a Costco pizza and a
Costco cake and we'll celebrate later
but listen they don't even have to tell
anybody just go get the D gum
certificate don't tell anyone and then
when you you can pretend like oh we
we're we set a date and we're getting
married like nobody knows at this point
they forgot I mean they they're like 12
it's been 12 Years everybody around them
thinks that they're married yeah that's
it's crazy listen if you're listening I
don't care if you've been dating for 8
years or 24 years if you don't have that
piece of paper and something goes wrong
you are not protected get married get
the piece of paper so that if something
goes aai the law is on your side to make
sure you get your cut come on ladies
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank y refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify I4 after
24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
your host Jade warshaw your other host
is George camel with a K don't get it
twisted and we're taking your calls all
afternoon long the number is 8825
5225 and we're coming George around the
pipe to my favorite time of year not
true tax season it's a whole season Jade
like we got birthday month but it's tax
season
season yes um I don't historically love
tax in Georgia I'm not going to lie
about that I It Feels stressful it feels
like all right like I got to start you
know people are sending me papers in the
mail they're emailing me papers I got to
download the PDF and send it to my you
know well at least your techsavvy and
young you know my mom I got to show her
how to get the PDFs downloaded and
printed it's a whole situation the PFD
the PFD no I get it I mean when I
schedule my tax appointment it might as
well be scheduling a colonoscopy that's
how it feels like I'm just preparing my
heart it it feels that I don't feel like
we have to feel that way I feel like
that's kind of just the stigma of taxes
but I feel like it can actually be
simpler oh well I like my tax I got a
tax Pro and I've enjoyed working with
them so I'm like I get to see them again
this year this will be fun get to catch
up but you know there with the stigma
Jade there's a lot of myths out there
and I released a video on my YouTube
channel called five taxsmith broke
people believe and uh not just broke
people a lot of people people believe
these and so I want to cover them real
quick the spark noes version okay and
then people can go watch the full
version with all the funny memes and
clips that we put in there and jokes but
this one's uh less jokes you ready for
it I'm ready myth number one a tax
refund is reason to
celebrate you've seen people bragging
and the commercials are all like woo I'm
going to Disney with my tax refund yikes
here's what this really is it's an
interest free loan you gave to Uncle Sam
oo yikes cuz that means you overpaid
your taxes all year long and they're
just giving you your money back so wait
a minute you're telling me that I loaned
the government money and they didn't
even pay me interest on it 0% is what
you got and then I have to file
something in order to get my money back
just to figure that out that's a problem
so think about it what could you do with
that money instead if you had it all
year long if you had $2,400 refund
that's $200 every month that you could
have been using to budget George listen
I know folks out here who are getting
like $8,000 refunds that hurts my my
brain they are giving the government way
too much we already do that enough with
taxes can we do a poll on that uh I want
to know like what folks are getting like
put put in the comments put in the chats
what you what is an average or like a
normal tax return amount for you I just
want people to see the amounts that
they're letting the government borrow
that'll be fun to see so the goal here
is to get to as close to zero as
possible yes that's you don't want to
give too much you don't want to owe too
much and you can just go on your W4 and
like change like they've made it easier
to change your withholding so work with
your HR team and you can adjust that
form and myth number two it's bad to be
in a higher tax bracket More Money More
Problems people are always scared of
making more money Jade because they're
like well I might push me into the 22%
tax bracket I'm like you don't that's
not how it doesn't even work like that
it doesn't and I walk through this
visually in this YouTube video we're not
going to do it here but tax rates are
marginal it's not your whole amount
that's taxed at yes thank youge this
first portion of your income is taxed at
10% this next portion is taxed at 12%
and it stair steps up yes and so if you
make an extra $2,000 you're not going to
be just jumping into wildly more taxes
people you got to think about the
effective tax rate instead of marginal I
walk through that in the video yes good
myth number three you've heard this one
keeping debt around is good for the
write off yeah bro I keep my house
payment for the tax write off you've
heard people tell don't pay off your
house you you'll lose the mortgage
interest deduction uh the numbers on how
many people actually itemize which by
the way is the only way you can get the
interest deduction yes such so abysmally
low yeah the standard deduction exactly
and and you don't think about what
you've been paying all year in interest
for the benefit and joy and blessing of
getting a little bit back so and then
there's just the peace right can we just
just the not having de so don't spend a
dollar to save a quarter that's bad math
that's stupidity and don't spend money
to make money you've seen the people are
like I'm going to buy a G wagon for
$24,000 and ride it off like a life hack
no no one thinks you're cool myth number
four you have to pay by tax day and if
you can't don't even bother paying at
all you missed it you missed the boat
that's a lie that's a lie do you know
what musical that's from I don't want to
embarrass myself dream girls but keep
going I was going to say Dream Girls
which would have been embarrassing so
that's why I didn't do it uh so yeah you
have options here don't ignore taxes
just because you can't pay by tax day
you got to file anyways right
it's paperwork right yes and you can
file an extension for the payment um but
this is you you got to pay as much as
you can and get on a payment plan and if
you do owe the IRS money put it to the
very top of your debt snowball oo good
one George that goes to the front of the
list cuz they can screw up your life and
garnish wages and take you to court it's
not you don't want to do that guys pay
your pay your taxes please don't mess
around with these IRS folks okay keep
going last myth you're not smart enough
to do your own
taxes hey hey I have felt that in in
times past I have felt that George well
they got all these forms and all they
ask you a billion questions and so
here's the deal it's become a lot easier
and this one depends some people it's
wise to do it yourself if you know if
you feel comfortable and some people
it's worth working with a pro so online
tax software can be great if you've got
one to two sources of income you don't
have a bunch of non-retirement investing
going on you're taking the standard
deduction you don't have any major life
changes like moves or marriage or
whatever um online tax software is great
and we actually have one called Ramy
smart tax there it is that is is
wonderfully easy to use it guides you
through the whole process there's no
gimmicks there's one price you pay one
flat fee and there's not this surise at
the end of oh you have one extra form
we're going to get you at this one like
the other guys do so they make it super
simple uh upfront pricing I love if I if
if I like literally me if I if I'm
looking at I'm going listen I can't do
my taxes I got a small business we just
had a baby his income is like that then
you're
looking and we've got a whole network of
ramsy trusted tax Pros all over the
country who are ready to help you with
that that you can trust they're not they
want they have a heart of a teacher they
want to actually educate you um and so
those two are great options so you can
go check that out ramseys solutions.com
tax our team created just an entire Hub
number one there's a few questions you
can select it's going to show you the
best option for you should you file
online which version should you work
with a pro and it'll give you the next
steps there's also a great guide to
taxes and some great checklists like
prep checklist I print this out every
year from this website so that you make
sure you're having all the paperwork for
your tax all my ducks in row cuz there's
always one I forget I'm like oh yeah I
need the the $10.99 I for the interest
income from the high yield all of that
is right there in the checklist so you
know you're you're ready to go when you
meet with the pro or you're filing
online I suddenly have less stressed
George that's the goal that is the goal
so rames solutions.com tax you know too
much now to fall for these myths y'all
and uh Happy tax filing I like to get
mine done as soon as possible truthfully
I am already there listen last night as
we were getting ready for bed I was cuz
Sam's mom is an accountant she's done
our taxes forever bless her and so I was
like did you send your mom the tax stuff
and he was like yeah I'm like did you
send her our giving statement the giving
statement you know you at church you
give your tithe that that checklist I
now too am going to go download that
checklist just to make sure because
there's always one or two things that
slip your mind and so it's nice to have
that checklist to to to remember all
those like you said 10.99 I all those
little things so go to ramsy
solutions.com tax you'll see U my face
you'll see Dave's face we're smiling
we're happy and it says you shouldn't
have to doubt your tax service so we've
got all kinds of options we'll walk you
through should you work with a pro
should you file and at the bottom you'll
see the free tax guide you'll see the
personal checklist even a self-employed
checklist yeah that can be stressful for
those that are self-employed listen I
want to roll back though George to that
myth number one about the refund being a
reason to celebrate I feel like people
y'all don't give yourself enough credit
cuz a lot of people just view it as hey
hey George this is this is how I say for
vacation every year listen it's easy my
tax refund comes and that's our trip to
Disney I really want to bust that myth
up because you could literally keep that
money in your account and have a better
rate you could put it in HSA hysa for 12
months and have a better rate of return
than letting the government hold it for
a year because you don't think you can
save money for a vacation yourself well
too many people are complaining they
don't have margin in their money right
now with inflation and I'm like well you
have margin you just are giving it to
the government all year and then you're
getting it at the end of the year so
change your withholding it's January
this is a good time to be looking at
that reset whatever you've been getting
over the past you know look back on
years past whatever you've been getting
take that number and divide it by 12
like George said that's the amount of
money you could be having back in your
budget every single month think about
that man with inflation that's groceries
that's gas money you just gave yourself
a raise okay I love it significant there
it is we ate our vegetables Jade we
taught the people about taxx are you
happy James James is never
happy this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsy show I'm
your host Jade warshaw this is your
other host George camel with the k your
producer James Childs he just told us we
did a good job and that rarely happens
you know how rare that is I mean he said
a good job you guys are gaslighting me
so bad right now know it's like the dad
who's never said he's proud of you and
then finally 20 years in he shakes your
hand and says handshake and he says take
care buddy yeah not a hug a
handshake okay I'm kidding he pulls a
quarter from behind his ear and says go
buy yourself something nice don't spend
it all in one place kid I love it he's
the best the guys in the booth are the
best guys ever and the gal and gal yes
IBU listen they're really the ones that
make this show happen let's be clear
about that um they I can't imagine being
the front lines of screening the phones
for this show they whisper all the
answers into our ear pieces that would
be amazing give us a call the number is
tri8 825 5225 we're just having a good
time and let's go straight to the phone
lines where we've got mark from New York
City New York what's going on
Mark hi Jaden George thank you so much
for taking my call you guys are my
heroes wow that's awesome you got you
got to set your sights higher but I
really appreciate
that
I uh appreciate your time um so I'm in a
unique in uh my wife and I are in a
unique uh situation um we have about
1.6 in um in a brokerage account 43 um
we have about a quarter million in um uh
retirement I also have I'm about 17
years in the uh public um retirement
system pension system in my job okay um
we have we owe about 260 on our primary
and around 113 on our rental property
okay and really what it comes down to is
um after listening to you guys I wonder
if if I I should use the um the
brokerage account to pay off the two
properties and become truly debt free um
we have no debt um cars are paid off um
no credit card debt it's just such a big
decision I'm just a a little I'd like to
get some advice you just need somebody
to kind of push you it's like jumping
out of an airplane you just need the guy
on your back to just jump and then you
you know what we're going to say the
question is what's holding you
back like 373 out of your 1.6 you're
still going to have $1.2 million sitting
in that brokerage
account and that's that's what my um um
my my um ADV advisor is saying uh
however I I I I got this money initially
from my grandmother when she passed away
as an inheritance I feel like I'm the
steward of this money absolutely and I I
just don't want to do anything wrong
with it I I pretty much have we've
basically Quint coupled the money and I
know this is a great problem to have I
just I'm so afraid of making the wrong
decision um listen the good news for you
is we teach we teach Grandma's way of
handling money like that's what a that's
our whole thing here so I I never met a
grandma that liked it I'm just saying me
neither I think your grandma if you if
if you talk to her now and you said
listen Grandma I took that money I paid
off all my debt my family is living debt
free we're millionaires we've got paid
for Real Estate our own home is paid for
I think she'd probably I don't I don't
know the woman but my guess is she would
be so very proud of
you I guess the only well thank you but
um I guess the other thing would be
opportunity cost with that
money um still invested would it
outstrip the um would it make more than
it's as an investment rather than um or
is this more of a just a um emotional
decision rather than purely numbers
decision well also the tax liability on
selling those uh Investments I'm I'm
wondering if that would would be an
issue as well well are these going to be
long-term capital
gains yes okay and you're not selling
all of it and so do the math on what you
would owe in taxes and we're going to
set that aside as well but again you're
still going to have over a million
dollar sitting here that money is going
to continue to grow do you need to touch
that money for any other
reason um no no we've used it in the
past like to you know the down payment
on this this our current home and things
of of that nature but like I said before
I really try to keep hands off of it as
much as possible okay well play it out
think about this too you have two
mortgage payments right now
take those mortgage payments and plug
them into investment calculator you're
43 let's say for the next 20 years you
start to invest that much more into that
same
account that's going to change the
numbers for
you that's I'm guessing a few thousand
dollars you're now investing that you
weren't before
correct yes absolutely I mean it would
definitely free up U cash flow that you
know in a way that we've never seen
before that's for sure and every if if
you get let's say a 10% average annual
return in this account if it's invested
well that money is going to double every
seven years so 1.2 turns into 2.4 turns
into 3.6 and you're still going to be
you know what in your 60s at that
point correct and that's if you do
nothing else that's if you just leave it
alone and you don't put another dime in
there so you're going to be okay so I'm
less worried about opportunity cost in
the future I'm more concerned about Mark
right now in his at 43 years old and the
freedom and options he gets to have with
his family with no payments in the
world it does sound very enticing maybe
it is uh I mean I obviously you know I
um called up because I wanted an answer
from people that I respect and trust and
I I be honest I probably have gotten the
answer that I expected so what are you
gonna do Mark the question is what are
you gonna
do I I'm gonna do it I make the call and
um we always joke if you regret it Mark
you can always go get more debt you can
take out against that all those equity
in your homes and get Hecks up to your
eyeballs that's
right I think going to mention that we I
was gonna mention that we have a low
interest rate but I know how that goes
over on your I keep that to
myself mark my favorite interest rate is
zero and that's what I have on my house
and that's what you're about to have
Rich people earn interest they don't pay
it exactly and you are a rich person and
your grandma left a beautiful Legacy and
I think she would want you to solve for
freedom and this is what Freedom looks
like man you get the O the world is your
oyster with no mortgage payment you guys
have done so well 43 years old net worth
I'm guessing we hadn't even hear the
full picture man with all what the
properties are worth plus the millions
in these accounts excellent Excell the
way he's going to be able to give save
and spend for the next 40 years is
mindboggling that's exciting it's so
hard you know th he's a math guy like
he's all into numbers they're they're
the hardest to remind about peace well
when it comes to emotion I can get
people to look at the math but when
people are mathematical it's hard to get
them to look at emotion it's so hard to
go what would that feel like and they go
well I don't know cuz on paper it's a
low interest rate I can make a spread if
I invested it yeah and they're losing
brain calories and sleep over this and
I'm going I yeah peace and no payments
man try it out see how you like it I
hear that let's ask Dennis Let's help
him out he's in white I think can right
Qui what's going on Dennis well it's not
white ples it's West ples W sorry about
that I got my glasses she was in a New
York State of Mind for I was I was how
can we help well I see all this stuff
and hear everything about the high yield
interest rates for the high yield
savings accounts and I've been looking
and trying to figure them out and
there's so many names I haven't seen
anywhere before I am looking for some
guidelines on what to look for in them
in order to know I'm picking something
that's going to work for me that's a
good question I love that um so is this
where you're parking your 3 to six
months of expenses or are you using it
for another reason well it's for to
three to six months and for taxes at the
end of the year okay so kind of
short-term savings go year well I'll
tell you there are a million out there
and we don't have one that we've
partnered with I can tell you one I
personally use and Jade can do the same
and Rachel Cruz can do the same but what
you want to look for here is one that
has low fees to no fees so monthly
maintenance fees no ongoing expenses and
one that you have easy access to and so
a high yield savings account is not like
a CD you can access that it's liquid at
any time you can transfer it to your
checking account so those are the
important things you want to look at and
of course the interest rate that's right
so what do you use Jade right now listen
I I love an online account I love Ally
there's not a lot of fees Associated
like you said the money is totally
liquid I don't attach it to any debit
card or credit cards or you know any
checks or anything like that cuz I don't
want easy access to it but at the same
time it's there if I need to pull it out
exactly I use one called Marcus again we
don't have any affiliation with these
but I tried to find one that's also not
tied to credit card companies and gross
debt products and you know that's hard
to do in the banking world but Ally and
Marcus are ones that I've I've heard
people have great experiences with so
just open one Dennis and set it and
forget it set it and forget it Ron pel
baby I love it this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
a
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and build amazing
relationships I'm your host Jade warshaw
your other host is George Campbell with
a K give us a call we'd love to hear
from you help you sort through your
issues with your money your
relationships your career the number is8
825 5225 we're here to help all right
George I say without further Ado we go
straight to these phone lines we've got
Mo in Columbus
Ohio hello Hi how are you doing
Mo good I'm doing well um I'm calling I
recently got a job promotion um and I've
been listening to the show for about
four months now um and I have some debt
um I don't have um really any guidance
when it comes to money I've cut off
Conta
um majority with my father um after um
some money issues and I'm just trying to
set myself up for Success um and I'm
wondering how best to go about it um
because I'm still new to um from what
I've listened to kind of trying to
follow the step okay so kind of help us
understand what you're trying to sort
through is it debt is it tell us
more um so it's debt and then um like
retirement plan um I have a little bit
of student loans a car payment um I
currently rent um and um will be moving
in May um to where it's more affordable
um after college I got a job and I had
to move out of my father's house okay um
and found the cheapest place that I
could but I I've kind of been money
hungry and like excited to start saving
I just I don't really know the best way
to go about things okay so okay good um
so let's find out what are you earning
what do you earn every month what do you
bring home so I was earning
62,500 a year and two weeks ago I found
out that I'll be getting promoted and I
will start traveling for work and my new
salary will be $78,000 okay so it was a
decent bump that's awesome and so each
month what do you see what does your
check look
like uh so I've only got
like the first since the first of the
year so but my new is it's pretty close
to four with the new salary okay great
so you got 4,000 bucks a month to work
with are you currently taking anything
out of your check for
retirement um currently my company
matches 6% so like dollar for dollar up
to 6% okay so that's what I have put in
and in one year I've generated like
$10,000 okay cool um 6% okay good now um
I just want to kind of know are are you
also using a budget is that part of your
life at this point I have somewhat of a
budget but as I with the pay increase
and I also in the spring will have a
little bit of a second form of income
um not exactly sure kind of what that
budget should look like okay um I have
like a general idea based on like my old
income but okay to that was hard because
I've had $10,000 of medical expenses um
why I was uh finishing my last semester
of college and um all of 2023 which I
that I have no medical debt that's all
paid off which has just kind of
prevented me from like being where I
want to okay so you're new to listening
to us obviously we filter everything
through these seven baby steps but all
of that is contingent it all rests on a
budget like it's that's the foundation
of all of this so we've just found over
the years that people who win with money
have budgets and they have a good budget
that they follow every single month
month and it really is that road map to
get them to their financial destination
that's where it all starts so the first
things first is I do want you coming out
of here um and I want you hooked up with
a budget that you're doing every single
month and that's through every dollar
but the next thing here is we're walking
through those baby steps and like I said
your budget's going to inform and show
you how much money you have to put
towards each baby step I have I have a
th000 nest egg sweet which I think is
like I don't know which step that is
that's baby step one so that's just
sitting in a savings
account sorry say that again is that in
a savings account the
$1,000 yeah it's it's in a like a money
market account excellent so that is baby
step one just getting $1,000 saved it's
just getting a safety net there between
you and life and then essentially your
own baby step two which is paying off
all of your debt except your mortgage so
that's the phase that you're at right
now and I want to come back to the fact
that you're putting away 6% um into into
your retirement and we teach that in
order for you to pay off debt quickly
you need as much money to throw at it as
possible Right all your extra money is
what you're throwing at your debt you're
making minimum payments on everything
just to satisfy that but all extra money
goes to your smallest debt and you need
extra money and so right now you're
giving away some of your extra money in
retirement which I think was a a good
natured Choice like you're thinking okay
I'm trying to be responsible let me do
retirement but there is a right
method in a right order to go about um
paying off debt and Building Wealth
ultimately and the first step is paying
off debt so if I were in your shoes I
would temporarily very temporarily pause
investing so I can have that 6% back in
my month-to mon M that's 400 bucks a
month for you that's really GNA help
speed up the debt
payoff yeah that makes sense so how much
total debt do you have you said student
loans what's left on the student
loans so when I graduated worked two or
three jobs through college so I
graduated with 16,000 and that's now
down to
12,677 right um my junior year of
college my car broke down and I had um
no help so I had I had to buy a car to
be able to transport myself didn't go
crazy but the with the car market it was
at 2018 Ford Fusion and it was 17,500
and I have that down to 6,500 okay good
all right and then you said something
about credit cards do you have credit
card debt
I have $1,700 on a credit card okay so I
my thought would be go lowest to highest
from what I understood right the credit
card and then my car payment has a 5.1%
interest and my student loans only have
like a 2.7 something percent interest so
I'm assuming I would pay the car percent
off first and clear that $6,500 next
well the way that we found is the best
way is by balance so we list those debts
in order by balance not necessarily bu
interest rate so in this case the
student loan is it just one giant
student loan for 12,000 or is it built
into a lot of little mini
ones um it's three they're they're each
I think about
4,000 a piece I don't remember exactly
um so in that case those would be next
you would do the the credit card then
you would make your minimum payment on
the student loan which satisfies all
those three manyi ones and then the
extra money you would look and say Hey I
want it to go on this mini $4,000 one
and you kind of have to you either have
to call it in some websites they have it
in there where you can actually
delineate that but some websites they
don't want you to do that so sometimes
you have to call it in but technically
those student loans would come next um
it sounds like and then the car but with
your income with the raise which by the
way
congratulations listen my girl is Grand
in debt you make 78 now way to go we can
clean this thing up fast I mean basic
math says if if you can throw 5 grand a
month for 4 months you're done four
grand a month for 5 months this thing's
done and you're about to free up 400
bucks a month by pausing investing
you'll be back to investing in no time
and when you do it's going to be 15% not
six so that's going to be sweet but
follow the plan it works I followed it
Jade followed it we believe in it that
much that's right way to go I'm proud of
you Mo this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
you are listening to the Ramsay show
thank you for listening to the Ramsay
show by the way we value it so much when
you take the time to like subscribe our
show when you log in when you watch it
on YouTube wherever you watch or listen
to podcasts we appreciate it I'm Jade
warshaw this is George camel our Ramsey
Show question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services Mr Appliance is a neighborly
brand that can make your appliances make
sure that your appliances are running
properly in the new year for appliance
parts repair and service find a Mr
Appliance near you at neighborly decom
Ramsey today's question comes from Emily
in Connecticut my husband and I earn
$106,000 annually and our only debt is
our $200,000 mortgage we have 10,000
saved for our emergency fund with a goal
of 24,000 my husband comes from a family
that made a lot of money but never saved
any because of this he has never seen an
amount of $10,000 in his life and thinks
that's more than enough he wants to give
10% of our savings to the church he says
we have been blessed abundantly and
quote should never feel comfortable I am
the one who oversees our finances and
wants to become financially stable but
my religion also says to let my husband
be the spiritual leader of our house how
should I go about this I want to save a
full emergency fund but at the same time
want to be
generous interesting a lot of layers to
This Ti massu ooh layers Len so one is
just the financial what is the right
amount for our emergency fund right two
is the how should we give and from where
and then three is this upbringing of
abundance for scarcity that they're
dealing with listen I I have a couple of
thoughts George the let's think about
the giving part cuz I love that the the
the I almost said the dad the husband
wants to be generous I love that um but
kind of the way I think of it as is when
you get paid it sounds like they're
tithers um um if you're a Christian
person a lot of folks practice a 10% 10%
in church I think okay tithe that's what
they're doing and my guess my guess is
if you wanted to really get technical
here whenever you earn your income
you're probably giving 10% of that
income and then whatever is left that's
what you're using to run your household
financially whether it's part of your
budget you know groceries or whatever or
it's setting aside for savings so
whatever is in their savings they
probably have already tithed from that
money um and my thought would be like
listen if he wants to give more then let
that be from your month-to-month
income like if he's like listen I don't
want to give 10% I want to give 15%
great like I love generosity but I
wouldn't say that you have to drain your
savings to give we need to separate the
buckets your emergency fund is for
emergencies your giving savings account
needs to be forgiving so number one I
would create separate accounts to keep
these separate number two I would
calculate your actual expenses every
month and multiply that by three or six
depending on your income situations
stability of your jobs but if it's my
wife and she says I feel more safe with
six we're going to have a six-month
emergency fund so he needs to also
understand where she's coming from and I
don't buy this whole like well I grew up
never seeing 10,000 so that's plenty
like that's a really weird way to think
about wealth and money well he might be
like listen $10,000 is a lot like some
people um and it's also not as much as
it used to be it's not as much as it
used to be but if you've never had like
I I can somewhat relate to this a little
bit if you've never seen $10,000 the
first time you see it and get it you're
like I am just you're like Hulk status
like you can't believe what you've done
um but I think that he needs to go ahead
and let that wear off and realize that
10,000 is good but start really thinking
about it in lines of what could happen
if your AC goes out and you live in
South Florida anyway you're easily
spending five to $7,000 on a new AC so
that money can dry up liid liquidy split
if you were to lose your job and your
income come how long the the purpose of
that is to sustain you if the worst
happens and for most of us the worst
happening is we lose our job right and
it's can you really cause your household
to move forward for 6 months with
$10,000 for most of us you know the
answer is no and you need a little bit
more um especially with what it looks
like their situation is well the
ultimate question was I want to save a
full emergency fund but at the same time
want to be generous I don't see those
things as going against each other at
you can do and this idea of should never
feel too comfortable well the more
wealth you you have the more you're able
to give and so I don't see it as oh well
we hit 10,000 I don't want to be
comfortable we need to start giving
money that's fine if you want to be more
generous but I don't conflate the
emergency fund with giving and I think
they both need to come have a come to
Jesus meeting no pun intended and go
here's how I'm feeling we need to meet
in the middle here we're going to have a
20,000 emergency fund we're going to set
up a separate account for giving and you
need to go to therapy for whatever
happened in your so read own your past
change your future he I feel like he
wants his giving to feel like a
sacrifice like he wants to feel it and
in his it feels like for him that's like
it's got to come out of savings but I
don't know about all that CU then the
HVAC goes out and you go well that's not
good we just gave gave away a thousand
bucks we needed for that so separate
them out l i kind of also want to talk
about this we probably should avoid it
but I'm the one who oversees our
finances oh yeah that's that's Thing One
and want to become financially stable
but my religion also says to let my
husband be the spiritual leader
it's interesting cuz she said she's the
one who oversees the finances but he's a
spiritual leader it just sounds like
they've got some conversations that need
to take place because you know Al I mean
you guys are a partnership like there's
in any partnership there usually is one
person that kind of like has the final
word or it's like this is it you know
what I mean like like Dave's the boss
here you know what I mean like but
there's plenty of people that speak into
the things that go on and I just think
that too many people see that as well I
don't get a vote because they're the
lead
like you need to have be speaking into
finances just as much if you don't have
a vote it's going to cause resentment
it's going to cause Financial infidelity
so read some books on this whole
spiritual leader thing because I think
there's a lot of misunderstanding around
what that really means when I was
growing up they used to say the guy is
the head but the woman is the neck and
I'm like oh that's good because think
about it cuz I'm like the head ain't
doing nothing with the neck without the
neck who's the rest of the body it's
just a weird George we're just talking
about the head and the neck okay sorry I
thought we were going to go analogy
broke down quickly it did that's let's
move on all right let's go to the phone
lines where we've got Joshua in Chicago
Illinois what's going on
Joshua Hi how are you guys doing we're
doing good how are
you uh I've been
better I'm sorry to hear that how can we
help is there anything we can do to
help um yeah I I had a couple questions
for you guys um I know I've kind of
reviewed your guys's website and I like
to watch your guys' YouTube videos um
and I know Mr Ramsey he typically
recommends with having debt that you pay
off the smallest amount first and you
kind of snowball um and you make your
minimum payments on your larger amounts
while you throw as much as you can't
your smaller amounts um I'm currently 24
um still living at home at the moment so
I don't really have too many expenses
but I got about $2,600 in credit card
debt and then $6,500 in student
loans um and the my kind of issue right
now is my One credit card um payment um
the interest rate on it is very high and
I'm getting um kind of Knocked Down On
It in the sense that I'll make a payment
and it's not really making a dent in if
so if I'm putting all of my money
towards the smaller amounts what's the
smallest Deb you have right now uh about
$400 how much are you putting on it um
about $100 a month roughly
extra uh yes okay what do you
make uh currently I make 16 an hour for
how many hours do you
work uh about 40 hours a week and what
do you
do uh I'm a automotive technician I work
for a dealership okay
um is this a long-term play for you like
are you in the industry that you want to
be in
uh no I'm actually exploring different
Avenues I just actually went today and
signed up to join the electrical um
Union here in Chicago okay um so it's
but that could take a few months to hear
anything about that and that's kind of a
longer term process so I'm trying to
before I if I do switch over um
careers um it's the opportunity does
become um I'm trying to get this paid
off as soon as possible yeah and the
issue here the issue here is not the
debt snowball whether it works or
whether it doesn't cuz it does work the
issue here is we don't have enough money
going towards it and so we've got to
find something where you're making more
money and until then we're supplementing
the job that you already have with more
work you're working 60 I mean you work
from home you don't have any kids you
don't have a wife no bills you're going
hard in the paint my friend until you
get this done because yeah throwing $100
a month it is going to barely move the
needle you need to pay this off in one
month like you need to get you an Uber
cart an instaart all of it and pay this
off in one month and you're going to see
this go out of your life licky split
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
you're listening to the ramsy show thank
you for listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw this is George camel George
camel host of The George camel show on
YouTube also author of Breaking Free
from broke his new book that is out now
that I predict George will make and
become a bestseller we'll know tomorrow
Jade for that prediction yeah the
bestseller list come out tomorrow either
way I'm proud of the work we did and the
the feedback and the impact it's having
is really what matters but the list is a
fun way to go to celebrate and so
congrats on you becoming an author in
the last few months listen this is a
really fun year for us it's a fun year
it's a fun job I think that we're very
very lucky and blessed for pinch myself
every day that we get to do this awesome
I bet whitne pin me you're stronger than
me no I'll let Whitney pinch you she
that's her job all all right let's go to
the phone lines where we've got Luke in
Chicago Illinois what's going on
Luke hi there how's it going doing good
how are you I'm doing well doing well um
hope you guys are doing well yeah how
can we help you just wanted to yeah just
wanted to give you guys a call um I've
uh I've got some some debt um and also
got some money tied up and some
investment accounts just wanted to see
um or get some advice um you know based
on my income you know what what should I
be doing um attacking that debt or um
kind of continue investing into uh
retirement cool tell us some numbers how
much debt do you
have so I have
20,000 uh on a
[Music]
car um currently making uh more than
double payments on that so I'm paying
11100 a month uh on that car okay um and
I have 3,200 uh in student loans okay
and I have 8,000 I have 8,000 tied up in
a rough area
okay well that's not debt you said tied
up you mean you've invested 00 yes okay
you kind of said it like it something
bad happened okay good I'm glad you got
some money in a Roth IRA so you only
have a car loan and the student loan
that's it correct okay what's your
income uh my gross income is
87,000 cool and what do you see every
month what do you bring home every month
from
that uh well it kind of depends from
month to month um I'm in a commission
based um position um my monthly
take-home on my base salary is 4,000 M
then my commission check is anywhere
from uh two to 4,000 somewhere in that
pocket cool cool cool all right and um
what's your living situation are you
renting do you have roommates tell us
more about that yeah I'm renting I have
uh two roommates in a three-bedroom
apartment I currently pay 1330 a month
in rent okay so the question here what's
what's your actual question for for us I
just wanted to see kind of um you know
in if you guys were to put yourselves in
my shoes um would you go ahead and kind
of attack that student loans and and pay
it off in full rather than continuing to
uh contribute to that ra iray um and
then kind of working on that car as well
um kind of wanted to get your guys'
thoughts on that yeah well you're doing
a lot of good things you're just doing
them all at once and so it's harder to
make progress and what I found was when
I started this financial Journey when I
paused investing and I just went all in
on debt payoff I felt so much progress
and motivation and it happened faster
and then when I got back to investing it
wasn't just a measly you know 3% or 5%
it was 15% and that allowed me to build
wealth with so much peace and confidence
just focusing on one thing at a time and
so that's what I'd recommend to you how
much are you investing right
now um right now ra re I'm putting about
500 a month into okay so think about
that you said you're doubling your car
payment which is an extra
550 if you paus investing you could
triple the car payment and pay it off
even
faster right and if you attack the
smallest de first that student loan is
that broken up into multiple or is that
just
one that's just one okay so that's
technically your smallest debt right yes
yes sir so what if you made the minimum
payment on the car loan and you took all
the margin you could muster up you
paused investing how much extra could
you throw at that student
loan 1 1500 bucks I could probably yeah
I could yeah so think about that it's
gone in a month and a half you just
knocked out that student loan you freed
up that payment now we apply that to the
car loan along with that extra, 1500 or
2,000 boom this thing's rolling man
you're debt free in like what eight
months that's amazing yeah and in March
you don't have student loans anymore
that's great that would be sweet and
then before the end of the year you're
back to investing and instead of 500
bucks a month it's going to be way more
than that
right and so that's what we would
encourage that's how we've personally
done it and uh I I don't think you'll
regret it that way how old are you I'm
22 okay dude you have so much time yeah
it's amazing way to go on that income
too at 22 that's a good job well and you
when you look at the math on it Jade you
know 15% of 87 Grand that's $133,000 a
year yeah so he would be investing over
$1,000 a month instead of 500 wow so he
just overd doubled the savings rate
which we know is the key to Building
Wealth absolutely wow how does that hit
you
Luke that's awesome that's awesome than
you guys so muches man oh thank you for
the call I love call I put a pep in my
step I'm excited for him I know me too
cuz I never want to go back into debt
but there's like an excitement when you
like get the plan and you're like this
is going to work I know I know I an
adrenaline rush we did a live stream um
gosh two weeks ago it was the break the
cycle live stream you can still go on
YouTube and watch it but um it was just
motivation around breaking that paycheck
to paycheck cycle just like we helped
luk do getting your money figuring out
how to pay off your debt finding margin
in your budget and I was looking through
the comments just to see if people were
enjoying the live stream and one person
put the way you talk about debt I get so
excited I wish I had debt to pay
off I'm like no you don't but thank for
the comment we get the sentiment it's so
funny let's take another call we've got
Carter in Austin Texas what's going on
Carter are you
there Carter I don't know okay there he
is going on how can we
help um well I I just heard about the
baby steps um from my old youth Minister
and I don't feel 100% convinced that my
my
wife's 100% in on it and
whatnot is she happy with the current
financial
plan I she she likes being able to go
out on weekends and and and doing things
like that well I guess she think
sacrifice is not going to be worth
it I I don't I don't know I don't think
that she sees the the the longterm
effect that it it's causing right now I
guess is it out of hand like tell us
more about your situation so we can see
like where you guys fit on this spectrum
how much debt do you guys have um I ran
the numbers like 20 minutes ago actually
it's a
5049 3 32 yes ma'am
32,00 uh 300 is with her with
29,9 63 of student loans and on my side
it's a vehicle loan the major one is a
vehicle loan of
12,000 okay let me just let me clarify
that so you said she's got a student
loan and it's
32,000 uh 29,9 63 okay 29,000 okay and
then you've got the car what is yours um
11,862 and then what else do you have
and then I've got a credit card for
732 um I get I don't know where um like
insurance or whatnot how that would be
but that's not a debt oh oh it was it
showed up so what else you mentioned
your car loan you got a student loan and
then the credit card but there's more
here medical uh 4 200 in medical bills
4200 yes ma'am and then we took
out a personal loans for see
2,300 or something like that okay and I
think that that's it I didn't know that
the insurance thing wasn't I don't it
just showed up on my my credit thing
what do you got does she know about all
these debts and the
amounts not fully okay there's the
problem yeah she needs to to be made
aware cuz I can feel you realize the
stress of all these payments I mean your
head spin and just trying to lay them
out for us are you the one that pays the
bills every month I do my best yes ma'am
I think that's the issue I think that
you yeah you're the only one who's seen
the full scope and you're the one who's
paying that bill every month online and
she has can we do that go ahead okay
we're going to gift you guys Financial
Peace University Carter and you're going
to watch these nine video lessons with
her that's her only commitment right now
and that'll get you on the same page
speaking the same language getting you
guys fired up and really showing you why
you're too you guys are too smart to be
this broke you can be so successful and
Wealthy at this young age with this
Bright Young marriage and see it
squandered in the payment sucks so hang
on the line we'll gift you one year of
Financial Peace University my friend but
watch it convince
[Music]
her
you're listening to the Ramsay show
scripture quote of the day each one
should test their own actions then they
can take pride in themselves alone
without comparing themselves to someone
else for each one should carry their own
load that's Galatians 6 verse 4-5 then
we've got this from Paul McCartney I
don't work at being ordinary listen I
don't either Paul spoking like a beetle
I don't work at being ordinary we want
to be extraordinary love it love it
let's go to the phone lines Jonathan
another one from Boston Massachusetts
that's your area George what's going on
Jonathan hi guys thank you so much for
taking my call so happy to be on the air
today awesome we're glad you're here how
can we
help so I'm calling I'm I'm 22 years old
I I've been working in construction and
um I make about a little over 60,000 a
year uh before taxes and so right now um
I still live at home with my parents and
uh they're very they treat me well and
they don't charge me rent um so I can
get a head start with saving money I'm
very fortunate situation to be in yeah
so and I thank them every day for it so
my question is I you know I've been I've
been wanting to save for a house but the
Boston Market is so expensive I have
about a 100,000 in a high yield savings
nice and so I'm just trying to decide if
I should you know on a single income in
Boston on 60,000 it's kind of impossible
to find anything so should I just deploy
most of that into a taxable I've already
maxed out my raw th for 2024 and I do
contribute to my 401k so I'm wondering
you know instead of just having all that
cash sitting in a high yield savings
should I stop really saving for a house
and prioritize moving that cash to my
taxable brokerage I see you're saying
hey if this isn't going to happen for
another you know four or five years as I
continue to save should I just invest it
for the longer term and then pull it out
later
on yes yeah because you know the only
way I think I could afford a house here
is you know if I maybe have a career
change something that makes a lot more
money so I'm kind of like torn exactly
you know what I should do because all my
family is in Massachusetts so I don't
really want to move out of the area but
at the same time you know having the
money even though it's in a high yield
savings it still feel kind of like I'm
missing out on potential opportunity
well right now man I remember saving up
for our house and our high yield savings
account was making 2% and we were doing
jumping jacks at that rate and so we are
at record highs right now I mean I'm
making 5 a half% in a high old savings
account it blows my mind so that's a
great option that's going to keep your
money safe and the problem with
investing it is if you're going to pull
this money out in the next 3 years well
you could see a dip yeah all it takes is
one stupid election and all of a sudden
everyone freaks out and your the
Market's down 18% or it's up 20% but
that's going to change your heart rate
and so if this is truly a long-term play
four five years plus then I'm fine with
you investing it in the taxable
brokerage account into an index fund or
something but if this is 3 years out and
you think you're going to do this sooner
the high yield is a great option with
some great rates right now mhm and I
might also go all right I'm going to go
rent for a year or two I'm going to go
get a condo outside of town that's what
I'm thinking you know so look at all of
the options are you I mean you don't
need a a huge single family home for
just Jonathan right now
right yeah no no for sure I I've been
considering Apartments um it's just CRA
even outside even outside the city like
I I live outside the city it's still
almost what area are we talking
2000 uh you're talking like outside
Boston so near like um L Massachusetts
okay like Drake and that yep exactly
North yeah yeah well I think you're
going to find much cheaper prices as you
go further out from the city and so I
would be looking at condos and
apartments it's still a great way to you
know get an asset and build wealth and
create a for savings plan how much are
you looking to spend like what are you
looking we talking three 400 grand for a
condo yeah yeah yeah I was doing the
math and it seems like I mean doing it
adding it into like a more like how much
house I can afford what I was getting
was about um it was showing like just
over 200 like 225,000 I could afford and
I was looking at cond condos in L it
still seems like most are um you know
just around the $300,000 range and
that's even before you know your broker
fees closing cost everything like that
yeah well think about this your income
is going to go up and I would encourage
you to find ways to do that you're
making 60k at 22 which is awesome you're
an impressive dude you've worked so hard
you're living on less than you make you
got no expenses you could pretty much
stack up all of that cash I mean could
you save up 30 grand a year at this
point 40 Grand a
year some side hustles to for sure yeah
yeah for sure I I do some I do some side
hustles and I also you know I always I
always like work during the weekend try
to pick up like extra hours here and
there like I said you know I'm in a very
fortunate situation where you know my
parents don't charge me rent I'm able to
save like a lot that money Now's the
Time I'd probably do this for another
year or two and if uh if you need to go
rent and just kind of get out of the
nest that's great too but I think you'll
be a homeowner within two years man you
got like 150 to put down on a 225 or 300
that mortgage is going to be real
reasonable 25% of your uh take-home pay
and you're in a great spot I love it
love our we had several of those this
morning or this morning this afternoon
it's cuz I'm on you're on and they know
that you're here Bostonian
no that's good that is great so George
you know I find that with these
conversations there's so much like with
the way the housing market is there's
like should I go should I not go is it
time is it not time should I stay or
should I buy home now there you go I
like it yes that's that's the ticket the
I'm trying to think who sings that song
James tell us the Verve the dri The
Clash CL I know it's something I'm like
it's um but you know these conversations
I feel like that's what everybody's
where everybody's at right now it's like
got this money it's going to take me a
while longer to get the money I truly
need for the down payment I want or for
the payment to be what I want it to be
do I just sit on that money or do I
invest it and I think the the um
argument that you laid out is really
important when you have a lump sum of
money that you are emotionally connected
to because this is your future like this
is your house this is that potential
mortgage to invest it if it's not going
to be longterm you're going to be
just on edge the entire time you're
going to be logging in all the time to
see like what's the market doing and
like you said if the market crashes you
are going to have a heart attack so that
money is truly best we've seen a lot of
that lately I mean it wasn't long ago
where we had the market was down 18% for
the year but then we've had a great year
so far this year and so but when you're
ready to make that home purchase you
don't want to be like oh gosh I can't do
it yeah cuz my 100 Grand turned into 85
oh so painful that's too stressful but
the longer you keep the money in there
the better chance that money has grown
and it's going to be a wise move so but
that's a great that's a rare situation
that someone has no debt and 100 Grand
sitting there at 22 absolutely what a
rockstar most people have debt up to
their eyeballs Jade and they're like
well I got to get a house cuz my parents
are pressuring me and the housing
Market's crazy and then they call us
again going I think we need to sell the
house we made a mistake you know and in
a situation like this guy too it is
worth noting it doesn't hurt to have
some rental history going into buying a
home especially with a zero credit score
it's a great caveat um and I would say
to to somebody like Jonathan it's great
when your parents say you can live here
rentree but it doesn't hurt to set up
some situation where you're paying them
rent so that you can show I've been
paying rent for you know I have a
renting history basically is what
they're going to ask for especially if
you go in with a zero credit score you
manual underwriting they need to see
that you've made some kind of rent
payment even if it's not Market rent of
1,200 bucks right if you've made a
regular payment on the first of the
month to your parents for 500 bucks that
is going to change the G when it comes
to getting approved for a no score loan
it's actually very very important so in
his case or if you're in that case you
can either look at paying your parents
or in this case it could be worth it to
get out on your own find some roommates
so that you're establishing that trade
line which is really really important
that's big time it is and I talk about I
have a whole chapter in my new book Jade
on home ownership and mortgages and I
walk through with a lot of empathy cuz I
feel for those out there man like it's
different you're right wages have not
kept up with the housing market it used
to be twice your salary could get you a
home now it's six times your salary is
what it takes to get a home and so it is
harder than it was before but don't let
that discourage you like renting is
smart is buying patience it's not a sin
it's not a waste of money I'm so sick of
these myths that we're telling young
people and guess what it's coming from
you parents cuz you want what's best for
your kid and you go well you got to get
in the game in the housing market your
kid can't afford it and if you can't
afford it it's a it's a burden it's not
a blessing a burden instead of a
blessing that's exactly right so you got
to do it the right way here's our
parameter for this 15year fixed rate
mortgage is the only one you want to go
with 25% of your take home pay going
towards the mortgage and have a solid
down payment if you do it that way
you'll buy a house with peace yeah how
much down payment George for those
asking 5 to 10% is okay for first-time
homeowners but I think 20% is a great
goal to have to avoid that pesky private
mortgage insurance which protects the
lender not you right usually insurance
is great cuz it protects you not in this
case ooh I love it another hour in the
books hosting with the great George
campel thanks for being here with me
today thanks thanks to the guys in the
booth Thanks James appreciate you you're
welcome this is the ramay
[Music]
show